bonjour
on va parler de sapiens de yum
harari harari est un
d'histoire israélien né en 1976 son
livre sapiens a été publié en langue
originale en 2011
il s'agit d'un best-seller mondial vendu
à plus de 27 millions d'exemplaires et
traduit dans 60 langues et l'ambition de
cet ouvrage c'est de retracer l'histoire
de l'humanité plus précisément de
retracer les grandes dynamiques de
l'évolution humaine dans l'histoire
la question à laquelle tente de répondre
harari dans son livre seb par quelles
circonstances homo sapiens est il devenu
l'espèce dominante sur la planète
une autre manière de poser la question
serait qu est ce qui fait la spécificité
de l'espèce humaine au sein du règne
animal et qui lui a permis de se hisser
au sommet de la chaîne alimentaire
puisque on peut estimer que manger sans
être mangés est un assez bon critère
d'évaluation du niveau de domination
d'un groupe
donc le livre sapiens est un livre de
maquereaux histoire c'est à dire que
l'auteur nous propose une vue d'ensemble
une vue panoramique sur l'histoire de
l'humanité ce qu'il conduit
inévitablement à gommer certaines
aspérités de l'histoire humaine pour
mieux en restituer la logique globale
et j'ajouterai que ce qui est très
appréciable dans ce livre c'est qu'en
adoptant cette perspective macro
historique harari s'abstient à quelques
exceptions près de tout jugement de
valeur sur le comportement des hommes
ils n'adoptent pas la posture de
justicier anthropologique ils n'adoptent
pas la posture de brigadier de la morale
il se contente de décrire une logique de
déploiement à travers son prisme bien
sûr mais sans tomber dans la facilité
moderne du jugement rétroactif parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a facilement tendance
à regarder dans le rétroviseur du passé
avec notre moderne et donc avec la
cargaison de nos représentations morale
qu'on voudrait pouvoir plaques et à des
époques et à des contextes qui n'avait
pas du tout la même configuration
le biais rétrospectif c'est le fait de
vouloir juger le passé à travers nos
catégories contemporaine
lorsqu'on comprend que les paradigmes
moreau sont indissociables de certaines
conditions matérielles de vie autrement
dit qu'on n'a pas la même morale quand
on vit dans un loft climatisé de 120
mètres carrés que quand on vit dans la
forêt et qu'on chasse le sanglier
quand on a compris ça va on a plutôt
tendance à s'abstenir de prononcer un
jugement moral sur ceux qui nous ont
précédés
donc de ce point de vue là harari
remplit parfaitement son rôle
d'historiens c'est à dire le rôle d'un
re transcripteur de la trajectoire de
l'humanité à travers les siècles
et c'est vrai que art arimany assez bien
l'art de la narration historique et
l'art de faire naître en nous des
interrogations et des réflexions
alors je fais tout de suite une
précision cet odieux ne sera pas une
note de lecture
si vous voulez entendre une note de
lecture je vous renvoie immédiatement à
l'excellente vidéo de michel drach une
vidéo d'environ deux heures extrêmement
complète est accompagné d'une critique
extrêmement pertinente de l' ouvrage de
harari ce qui ne sera pas le cas dans
cet audio puisque le but de cet audio ça
va être d'initier une réflexion à partir
d'une des lignes de force principale du
livre de harari et cinq lignes de force
j'estime être la colonne vertébrale du
livre c'est l'idée que sapiens se
distingue des autres animaux en cela que
son existence est organisée autour de
fiction partager
et l'idée d'art harris est de dire que
parce que sapiens est un animal créateur
de fiction créateur de réalité
imaginaire
il est du même coup un animal capable de
coopération
de coopération avec ses semblables c'est
à dire avec ceux qui partagent les mêmes
fiction
et c'est cette idée sur laquelle on va
se pencher
alors pour commencer il faut préciser
que cette idée selon laquelle l'homme
serait un animal créateur de fiction un
animal symbolique n'est pas précisément
une idée nouvelle
on la trouve déjà chez aristote lors ce
qu'aristote définit l'homme comme un
animal politique animal vivant dans la
police la cité et lorsqu'à resto définit
l'homme comme un animal politique
il veut dire que l'homme est le seul
animal qui établit des coopérations avec
ses semblables pour pouvoir survivre
autrement dit si les hommes vivent en
groupe si les hommes créent des sociétés
c'est parce qu'ils sont conscients
qu'ils sont plus forts en nombre c'est
le célèbre adage qui dit l'union fait la
force
et donc les hommes ayant compris
l'utilité de l'association ayant compris
l'intérêt de coopérer ils ont créé les
sociétés c'est à dire des territoires
sur lesquels vivraient des individus
partageant un monde symbolique commun
parce qu'une société ne se définit pas
seulement par une délimitation
territoriale pour faire société
il ne suffit pas de partager une zone
géographique il faut également partagé
un langage c'est à dire un système de
signes permettant d'échanger et de
communiquer du sens il faut partager des
lois des normes des valeurs c'est-à-dire
qu'il faut partager un imaginaire
symbolique est ce qui fait le propre
d'une culture c'est qu'elle est
indissociablement un système de normes
un système de représentation et d' usage
collectif qui permettent aux individus
qui la partage de vivre dans un monde
commun le monde commun étant à la fois
matérielle le territoire et immatériel
l'imaginaire symbolique donc la
définition par aristote de l'homme comme
animal politique comme animal
établissant des coopérations sur fond de
monde commun constitue en quelque sorte
la matrice originelle de l'idée que
développe harari dans son livre et cette
idée a d'ailleurs été largement
développée à partir du 19ème siècle
notamment avec l'invention de la
sociologie et d'ailleurs il existe un
courant de la sociologie contemporaine
qui s'appelle la sociologie de
l'imaginaire qui travaille justement à
décrire et à décortiquer les imaginaires
collectifs sur lesquels les sociétés
fonctionnent
l imaginaire collectif c'est la
structure immatériel qui font de l'ordre
matériel
c'est la structure imaginaire et
symbolique qui ordonne et réguler les
comportements sociaux
mais ce qui est plus nouveau dans le
livre d'art harry c'est la
systématisation de cette idée m à tous
les phénomènes humains de grande ampleur
c'est l'idée que cette tendance de
sapiens à créer des fictions est le
véritable moteur de toutes les
révolutions qui ont guidé l'histoire de
l'humanité et que si on ne prend pas en
compte le fait que l'histoire de
l'évolution humaine est guidé par des
fictions entièrement guidé par des
fictions alors le sens profond et
véritable de la destinée humaine nous
échappe
son prend pas en compte le fait que les
fictions sont le moteur de l'histoire
alors on ne peut pas comprendre
l'histoire une bonne partie de
l'histoire tourne autour de cette
question comment convaincre des millions
de gens de croire des histoires
particulières sur les dieux les nations
où les sociétés anonymes à
responsabilité limitée quand ça marche
pourtant cela donne aux sapiens un
pouvoir immense parce que cela permet à
des millions d'inconnus de coopérer et
de travailler ensemble à des objectifs
communs
essayez donc d'imaginer combien il lui
était difficile de créer des états des
églises ou des systèmes juridiques si
nous ne pouvions parler que de ce qui
existe réellement comme les rivières les
arbres et les lions alors maintenant si
on veut bien comprendre la thèse d'art à
rim il va être indispensable de
s'arrêter sur cette notion de fiction
qu'est ce qu'une fiction une fiction
c'est une réalité imaginaire
intersubjective intersubjective
signifiant partagé par un ensemble
d'individus donc en tant qu réalité
imaginaire la fiction n'est ni une
réalité objective
la seule réalité objective étant le
monde physique
mais la fiction n'est pas non plus une
réalité subjective
parce qu'une réalité subjective ne
permet pas à elle seule d'établir des
coopérations
la fiction dont parle harari ce n'est
pas par exemple
l'ami imaginaire parce que l'ami
imaginaire
vous êtes le seul à le voir ou à
l'entendre et a priori vous n'arriverez
à convaincre personne que cet ami
imaginaire à une existence en dehors de
votre seul esprit
une réalité intersubjective c'est une
réalité issu de l'esprit collectif
elle n'est pas objective au sens où elle
n'est pas matérielle elle n'est pas
observables et mesurables mais elle
n'est pas non plus purement subjective
elle n'est pas le fruit de l'imagination
d'un individu isolé
alors certes une réalité purement
subjective peut devenir une réalité
intersubjective à condition qu'elle soit
adoptée par un nombre suffisamment
grande individus pour devenir une
fiction partager
mais évidemment pour devenir collective
pour devenir une réalité intersubjective
une fiction doit avoir une fonction et
la fonction d'une réalité
intersubjective c'est de favoriser la
coopération
une fiction collective c'est une
abstraction à laquelle on se réfère dans
un but organisationnel
une réalité intersubjective c'est une
fiction adoptée par un groupe parce
qu'elle est un facteur d'unification et
de stabilité sociale
et vous allez voir que les exemples de
fiction collective sur lesquelles on va
s'attarder sont extrêmement variés et
parfois ne sont pas considérés comme des
fictions
c'est à dire que beaucoup de fictions
auquel nous croyons nous apparaît
spontanément comme des vraies réalités
comme des réalités objectives
car évidemment le propre d'une fiction
c'est qu'elle ne se manifeste pas dans
nos consciences comme une fiction
une fiction collective elle se donne à
notre esprit comme une réalité objective
car sitôt qu'on cesse de la considérer
comme une réalité elle ne remplit plus
sa fonction sa fonction d'unification sa
fonction de ciment social sa fonction de
réalité partagée
alors évidemment pour que ce soit le
plus concret et donc le plus
compréhensible possible on va donner
quelques exemples
et vous allez constater que si certains
de ces exemples vont vous sembler
évident certains autres risquent de vous
étonner
pour illustrer la tendance de sapiens à
créer des fictions et à considérer ces
fictions comme des réalités objectives
harari prends un exemple assez amusant
c'est celui du lion peugeot
le lion peugeot qu'est ce que c'est ben
c'est tout simplement le logo de la
marque qui produit des véhicules est
d'ailleurs rappelons que le logo vient
de logos qui signifie esprit est ce que
diarra rice et que la marque peugeot
n'est pas une entité réel
c'est une entité fictives c'est à dire
que peugeot
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui existe
matériellement peugeot c'est une société
une société repose sur des statuts
juridiques sur des contrats c'est à dire
finalement sur des morceaux de papier
des morceaux de papier avec des
inscriptions à l'encré lancre étant ceux
qui ancre la fiction dans le réel
et donc où est ce que peugeot existe
réellement il existe dans l'esprit de
ceux qui y croient
alors évidemment c'est bizarre dit comme
ça parce qu'on peut dire oui mais les
voitures que produits peugeot elles
elles sont bien réelles
de la même façon que peugeot possède un
siège social qui est situé dans un
bâtiment bien réel un bâtiment qui a une
adresse de domiciliation une adresse
physique c'est vrai mais ça ça
correspond à ce que harari appelle les
effets matériels de la fiction peugeot
et donc tous les employés de peugeot de
même que tous les usagers de véhicules
peugeot sont en réalité tous reliés par
une réalité inter subjective
une réalité qui n'existe que dans leur
esprit
évidemment ce qui est valable pour
peugeot est valable pour toutes les
autres marques pour toutes les autres
sociétés que ce soit facebook que ce
soit google que ce soit youtube
c'est à dire que physiquement parlant
youtube n'existe pas
youtube n'existe que dans notre esprit
pour le dire autrement c'est nous qui le
faisons exister
et c'est parce que nous partageons tous
cette réalité imaginaire qui s'appelle
youtube que youtube existe
et donc l'idée c'est de dire que 12
système de coopération humaine a pour
fondement la croyance en une fiction
collectivement partager
je répète parce que c'est très important
tout système de coopération a pour
fondement une fiction collectivement
partager
alors bien entendu le lion peugeot n'est
pas le seul exemple de fiction créé par
l'homme il s'agit là d'un exemple tout à
fait anecdotique qui illustre le fait
que nous vivons parmi d'innombrables
fiction dont nous ne soupçonnons même
pas l'existence des fictions que nous
n'envisageons pas comme fiction
si on pense à toutes les fictions qui
ont façonné l'imaginaire de l'homme
depuis la préhistoire
il est évident que la première fiction à
laquelle on pense c'est dieu
il faudrait d'ailleurs dire les dieux
car dans l'histoire le polythéisme
précède le monothéisme et son votre
rigoureux l'animisme précède lui même le
polythéisme l'animisme cette idée que
tout ce qui existe dans le monde naturel
est une partie de la divinité
est ce que nous dit harari c'est que
l'animisme est une forme de fiction
collective totalement adapté à
l'humanité préhistorique qui vivait
essentiellement au contact des éléments
naturels
il paraît logique que l'animisme et
était la première forme de fiction
collective puisque lorsque notre vie
quotidienne s'organise autour des
éléments naturels
lorsqu'on vit dans la forêt comme le
chasseur ou le fourrage heures que notre
survie dépend des fruits que nous
cueillons des animaux que nous chassons
qu'une plante peut nous guérir ou qu'un
champignon peut nous tuer bien il n'est
pas du tout absurde de considérer que la
nature est un monde peuplé de divinités
et de la même façon qu'il est logique
que l'animisme soit issu de la vie en
forêt il est tout aussi logique que le
monothéisme soit issu du désert un
désert dans lequel l'homme est seul
seul face au soleil
seul face à la lumière et à la vie
on peut revenir à la question des
fictions collective les divinités sont
les premières fictions collective de
l'homme et on sait d'ailleurs que dans
les sociétés polythéistes les dieux
étaient les gardiens de l'ordre social
ce n'est pas un hasard si toutes les
sociétés polythéistes possédaient leur
dieu de la guerre leurs dieux des
moissons leur dieu dollar ou leur dieu
de l'amour
de la même façon avec l'apparition du
monothéisme dieu devenait le gardien de
l'ordre moral
il devenait le prescripteur de nos
comportements individuels et collectifs
il nous indiquait le bien et le mal est
donc là encore dieu avait cette fonction
d'unification et de cohésion de l'ordre
social
donc la religion dont l'étymologie
latine religare et signifie rollier
avait bien cette fonction de liaison et
de communion des membres du groupe
c'est parce que la religion donne des
repères communs des règles communes une
destinée commune qu'elle est apparue
dans l'histoire comme l'un des plus
puissants vecteurs d'unification
elle est apparue dans l'histoire comme
l'un des plus puissants moteurs de la
coopération
alors la religion n'était évidemment pas
le seul exemple de fiction ayant façonné
l'imaginaire des hommes
il est vrai que lorsque l'on parle de
fiction humaine il est fréquent que
l'exemple de la religion se présentent à
notre esprit en premier
mais harry prend un deuxième exemple
deuxième exemple de fiction dont le
résultat était là encore de favoriser
considérablement la coopération entre
les hommes
on peut même dire que c'est à travers
cette fiction larmes que c'est
véritablement engagé le processus
d'unification du monde
ce deuxième exemple ce sont les empires
en pire c'est un ensemble de nations un
ensemble de peuples
obéissant aux mêmes ordres politiques
les sujets d'un empire obéissent aux
mêmes lois aux mêmes normes juridiques
et n'était pas rare que les nations
soumise à un empire puisse conserver
leurs coutumes leurs normes et leurs
croyances collectives sans pour autant
compromettre leur appartenance à un
empire on pense par exemple à l'empiré
romain à l' empire chinois ou même à l'
empire britannique qui abritait une
grande diversité culturelle
lorsque l'un d'eux faisait partie de
l'empiré britannique les indiens n'ont
pas pour autant perdu leurs usages et
leurs traditions
ainsi les empire unifié des peuples des
nations et des cultures extrêmement
diverses et même s'ils ont imprégné la
culture locale même si la gare
ferroviaire de mumbai porte les
stigmates de l'architecturé britannique
néogothique
le fait est que les nations soumise au
joug impérial continue à disposer d'une
relative indépendance culturelle
mais ce qui conférait aux empires une
relative homogénéité homogénéité dont la
fonction était de favoriser la
coopération
c'est l obéissance à un même ordre
politique
autrement dit appartenir à un empire
c'était appartenir à un ensemble de
nations soumises aux mêmes règles
soumises aux mêmes structures
unificatrice
l'exemple des empires n'est peut-être
pas le plus intéressant pour comprendre
ce que harari a plaidé réalité
intersubjective
et donc on va maintenant s'intéresser au
troisième exemple de fiction collective
que donne harari dans son livre un
exemple beaucoup plus surprenant
beaucoup plus inattendue puisqu'il
s'agit de l'argent
car en fm et même si on a fortement
tendance à l'oublier
l'argent est une fiction
la monnaie est une fiction
matériellement un billet de banque c'est
un morceau de papier
et un morceau de papier n'a pas de
valeur en soi il n'a pas de valeur
indépendamment de la valeur dont
l'investissent ceux qui l'utilisent de
la valeur dont l'investissent ceux qui
croient la valeur de l'argent repose
toute entière sur la croyance en la
valeur de l'argent
c'est à dire que lorsque vous donnez un
billet de 20 euros en échange d'un objet
la personne qui vous vend l'objet a
confiance dans la valeur du billet que
vous lui donnez et avoir confiance ça
veut dire qu'elle sait que quelqu'un
d'autre
acceptera lui échanger un objet en
échange de ce morceau de papier
ainsi tout système monétaire fonctionne
sur la confiance dans la valeur fictive
dont on investit la monnaie
et d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que
la création de fausse monnaie est
considéré comme un crime dans certains
états et qu'elle peut même être passible
de la peine capitale
parce que créer de la fausse monnaie
c'est trahir la confiance que l'on place
dans l'état l'état étant le garant de la
valeur des change de la monnaie
la monnaie n'a de valeur que celle que
l'on consent collectivement à lui donner
et si l'on perd notre confiance
collective dans la monnaie la monnaie
n'existe plus
lorsque les pièces de monnaie étaient
frappées à l'effigié du souverain
c'était une manière de dire que l'état
en garantie c'est la valeur
quentin aureus d'or était frappé à
l'éffigie de jules césar
ça signifiait que jules césar en
personne en garantie c'est la valeur
et quand on emploie le mot crédit pour
parler d'un prêt bancaire il ne faut pas
oublier que crédit ça signifie confiance
comme lorsqu'on dit qu'on accorde du
crédit à quelqu'un
le crédit du latin credo qui signifie
croire c'est le prêt d'une somme
d'argent accompagné de la confiance dans
la capacité de remboursement
parce que s'il n'y a pas confiance dans
la capacité de remboursement vous
n'obtenez pas votre crédit
le crédit c'est donc littéralement la
confiance dans l'avenir parce que prêter
de l'argent suppose une confiance dans
le fait que l'argent sera remboursé dans
l'avenir
et c'est là qu'on en arrive à la thèse
défendue par harry à propos du
capitalisme le capitalisme est une
religion car le capitalisme repose sur
une fiction qui est l'argent sur une
fois dans la croissance et qui nous fait
considérer l'argent comme une réalité
objective alors que l'argent n'est
qu'une réalité inter subjective
la valeur de l'argent n'est pas
objective la valeur de l'argent et inter
subjective c'est à dire qu'elle a son
origine dans un ordre imaginaire
elle a son origine dans une croyance
collective
coquillages et dollars n'ont de valeur
que dans notre imagination commune leur
valeur ne tient pas à la structure
chimique des coquilles et du papier ni à
leur couleur ni à leur forme
autrement dit la monnaie n'est pas une
réalité matérielle mais une construction
psychologique
elle opère en transformant la matière en
esprit mais pourquoi il réussit elle
pourquoi êtes vous prêt à servir des
hamburgers à vendre des polices
d'assurance maladie ou à faire du baby
sitting camp pour tout prix de vos
peines
vous ne recevez que quelques bouts de
papiers colorés les gens sont disposés à
faire ce genre de chose quand ils ont
confiance dans les fruits de leur
imagination collective
la confiance est la matière première
dans laquelle toutes les catégories de
monnaie sont frappés donc vous voyez ici
je pense que ce cas rares y appelle une
fiction collective ce qu'il appelle une
réalité intersubjective ce n'est pas une
croyance surnaturel ce n'est pas une
croyance qui ferait nécessairement
intervenir d être transcendant
une réalité intersubjective est une
croyance collective en une réalité
imaginaire qui permet l'unification la
cohésion et la coopération au sein d'un
groupe
or la religion les empires et l'argent
nous rendre capables de coopérer avec
des inconnus
et l'argent davantage encore que la
religion parce qu'on l'a vu la religion
concerne d'abord la cohésion entre les
membres du groupe mais elle ne permet
pas la cohésion entre des groupes
différents
là où l'argent va justement être capable
d'unifier et de faire coopérer des
groupes structurés par des religions
différentes
quand il s'agit d'argent tout le monde
est de la même religion l'argent est une
religion qui unifie au delà des
religions
c'est ça selon harari qui différencie
fondamentalement l'espèce humaine des
autres espèces animales
parce que oui les autres animaux sont
capables de communiquer ils sont
également capables de coopérer mais ils
ne sont pas capables de coopérer à
grande échelle
ils ne sont pas capables de coopérer
avec des inconnus
d'ailleurs sur cette question harari
explique bien dans son livre en quoi le
langage humain a permis d'étendre
considérablement les possibilités de
coopération puisque le langage concrets
que harari appelle le bavardage ne
permet pas de dépasser un certain seuil
de coopération un seuil qui quantifie à
environ 150 individus
c'est à dire que le langage concret ne
permet pas de dépasser les limites de la
tribu
au contraire le langage abstrait le
langage spécifique de sapiens permet
d'outrepasser les limites affective et
charnelle de l'échangé linguistique et
ça c'est extrêmement important parce que
c'est à partir de la création du langage
que les fictions c'est à dire les
réalités intersubjective donc les mythes
les symboles les dieux ont pu commencer
à circuler et donc à favoriser la
coopération à grande échelle
et si on ne comprend pas en quoi la
fiction a permis à sapiens de s'unir au
delà des limites tribales au delà des
limites de la communauté physique
quotidienne alors il devient impossible
de comprendre comment le règne de
sapiens s'est étendue sur la planète
si vous avez compris qu'une fiction
collective n'était pas la croyance dans
un ordre surnaturel mais dans un ordre
imaginaire autrement dit que la fiction
englobe toutes les productions de
l'esprit
aussi bien les lois que les valeurs ou
les idéologies alors vous comprendrez du
même coup que pour à rim il n'y a pas de
différence de nature entre la croyance
en dieu et la croyance dans les droits
de l'homme
car pour peu qu'on observe ces deux
systèmes de croyances d'hanoï
scientifique
dans les deux cas on a bien affaire à
deux fictions
on a bien affaire à deux productions de
l'esprit
dieu et les droits de l'homme
combat
je sais beaucoup d'entre vous on s'y
remet enfin on peut pas comparer ces
deux choses on ne peut pas mettre sur le
même plan la croyance en dieu et la
croyance dans les droits de l'homme
ah bon
et pourquoi
parce que la croyance en dieu serait
fondée sur une invention pure alors que
les droits de l'homme s'appuierait sur
une réalité objective
mais laquelle
les droits de l'homme ne sont pas une
réalité objective
les droits de l'homme sont une invention
intellectuelle et philosophique
ils sont issus de la philosophie des
lumières qui affirme que tout être
humain possède des droits inaliénables
mais d'où viennent ces droits sinon de
l'esprit humain
d'où vient le concept de liberté le
concept d'égalité
le concept de propriété sinon de
l'esprit humain
les droits n'existent pas objectivement
qui existent objectivement ce sont des
capacités ce sont des forces mais en
aucun cas les droits n'existent dans la
nature
dans la nature le seul droit qui est une
existence c'est le droit du plus fort
ce qui est précisément le contraire du
droit
et quand on affirme que les droits de
l'homme sont une réalité objective on
naturalise une conception normative
et le caractère universel des droits de
l'homme n'est rien d'autre que la
croyance culturelle dans le caractère
universel des droits de l'homme
de la même façon l'égalité n'est pas une
réalité mais une fiction philosophique
et juridique qui permet la coexistence
entre des individus dotés de capacités
inégale
alors évidemment ça nous paraît choquant
parce que nous aujourd'hui nous
considérons que les droits de l'homme
ont une réalité ne considérons pas les
droits de l'homme comme une fiction
nous ne considérons pas comme une
croyance mais c'est précisément parce
qu'il s'agit de notre croyance
collective que nous ne la considérons
pas comme une croyance collective
le propre d'une croyance c'est qu'elle
n'apparaît pas à l'esprit comme une
croyance
elle apparaît comme une réalité
objective
et ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ait tort de
croire dans les droits de l'homme ça
veut dire que croire dans les droits de
l'homme c'est croire dans les droits de
l'homme
il n'existe rien qui ressemble à des
droits en biologie juste des organes des
facultés et des traits caractéristiques
si les oiseaux volent
ce n'est pas qu'ils aient le droit de
voler mais parce qu'ils ont des ailes et
il n'est pas vrai que ses organes ses
facultés et ses caractéristiques soit
inaliénable beaucoup subissent des
mutations constantes et peuvent se
perdre totalement au fil du temps il
convient donc de traduire les droits
inaliénables en caractéristiques mu abl
cette forme de raisonnement ne manquera
pas de scandaliser les tenants de
l'égalité et des droits de l'homme qui
rétorqueront sans doute nous savons bien
que les hommes ne sont pas égaux
biologiquement
mais si nous croyons que nous sommes
tous foncièrement égaux cela nous
permettra de créer une société stable et
prospère
je n'ai pas d'objection c'est exactement
ce que j'appelle un ordre imaginaire
nous croyons à un ordre particulier
non qu'il soit objectivement vrai mais
parce qu'ils croient en nous permet de
coopérer efficacement et de forger une
société meilleure
les ordres imaginaire ne sont ni des
conspirations excécrable ni devin mirage
ils sont plutôt la seule façon pour les
hommes de coopérer effectivement et pour
illustrer cette idée harari prend deux
exemples de systèmes normatifs
diamétralement opposés mais qui se
rejoignent sur leur prétention à
l'universalité
et d'ailleurs harari joue de la symétrie
chronologique entre ces deux systèmes
puisque l'un date d'environ 1776 avant
notre ère et l'autre date de l'an 1776
de notre ère
il s'agit du code d'hammourabi robe
babylone et de la déclaration
d'indépendance américaine
alors voilà comment harari résume ces
deux déclarations
le code d'hammourabi repose sur une
hiérarchie des classes ainsi la vie d'un
esclave d'un roturier ou d'un homme
libre n'a pas la même valeur
et la peine encourue pour avoir commis
un crime envers un individu appartenant
à l'une ou l'autre de ces catégories
sera différente et tiendra compte de
cette hiérarchie
et à la hiérarchie des classes se
superpose une hiérarchie des sexes la
valeur de la vie d'un homme étant
estimée supérieure à celle de la vie
d'une femme
al'inverse la déclaration d'indépendance
américaine repose sur une stricte
égalité des individus tous les êtres
humains étant pourvus des mêmes droits
inaliénables tels que la vie la liberté
et la recherche du bonheur
or dans les deux cas les principes sont
justifiées par une autorité supérieure
considéré comme absolue les deux textes
nous met en présence d'un dilemme
évident le code d'hammourabi comme la
déclaration d'indépendance américaine
prétendent tous deux esquisses et des
principes de justice universelle et
éternelle mais selon les américains
tous les hommes sont égaux alors qu'ils
sont résolument inégaux pour les
babyloniens bien entendu les américains
dirait qu'ils ont raison camou ravis se
trompent
naturellement hammourabi protesteraient
qu'il a raison et que les américains ont
tort en fait hammourabi et les pères
fondateurs américains imaginent est
pareillement une réalité gouvernées par
des principes universels et immuable de
justice comme l'égalité où la hiérarchie
or ces principes universels n'existe
nulle part ailleurs que dans
l'imagination fertile des sapiens et
dans les mythes qu'il inventait se
racontent ces principes n'ont aucune
validité objectif il l'intérêt de cette
approche c'est qu'elle tend à
relativiser l'opposition que l'on a
coutume d'établir entre les partisans de
la croyance religieuse et les partisans
de nos idéologies modernes
mais si on prend du recul et qu'on
s'intéresse uniquement au phénomène de
la croyance en tant que tel c'est à dire
le fait qu'il n'ya pas de différence de
nature entre nos religions et nos
idéologies puisque tous deux procès d'
de fiction imaginaire et bien ce moment
là on comprend beaucoup mieux le
rapprochement auxquels procède harari
entre ces idéologies apparemment si
éloignées
et là où certains verront dans la proche
d'art harry une sorte de relativisme
déplace eh bien finalement cela donne
raison à harari puisqu'ils font la
preuve qu'il considère la fiction en
laquelle il croit comme une réalité
objective
or une idéologie une philosophie ou une
religion quelle qu'elle soit ne sont par
définition pas des réalités objectives
et là je vous renvoie à ce que disait
emmanuel kant à propos du rapport entre
subjectivité et objectivité
quand tu disais que tout ce que nous
appelons objectif n'est en réalité
objectif que du point de vue de notre
subjectivité
l'objectivité est un mythe l'objectivité
est une fiction en ce sens qu
l'objectivité ne peut pas être
appréhendées autrement que par une
subjectivité
parce que tout ce que nous pensons comme
objectif nous pensons comme objectif à
partir de notre esprit
or par définition notre esprit est
subjectif tout esprit humain est soumis
à des biais une subjectivité à un parti
pris qu'on le veuille ou non
et c'est ce qui fait précisément qu'en
tant que moderne occidentale vous
n'allez pas raisonner voir le monde de
la même façon qu'un forage heures de la
préhistoire ou quel artisan du moyen âge
parce que l'inscription dans un
paradigme culturel dans un paradigme
social dans un paradigme linguistique va
orienter votre manière de voir le monde
d'une manière telle que tous les
concepts que vous allez considérer comme
objectifs ne sont en réalité objectif
que du point de vue de votre
subjectivité
rien de ce qui sort de l'esprit humain
cet objectif
on admet volontiers que le code
d'hammourabi n'est qu'un mythe
mais nous ne voulons pas entendre que
les droits de l'homme sont aussi un
mythe
y at il un risque que la société
s'effondre si les gens s'aperçoivent que
les droits de l'homme n'existe que dans
l'imagination
dieu n'existe pas des et voltaire mais
ne le dites pas à mon vallée il me
trucide ray dans la nuit hammourabi en
aurait dit autant à propos de son
principe de hiérarchie et est thomas
jefferson au sujet des droits de l'homme
homo sapiens n'a pas de droit naturel
pas plus que non non les araignées les
hyènes et les chimpanzés mais ne le
dites pas à l'eau domestique il nous
trucide ray dans la nuit et là comment
ne pas voir le parallèle avec nietzsche
et sa théorie des arrières monde
on rappelle que pour nietzsche les
valeurs telles que le droit où l'égalité
sont des créations culturelles inventé
par les faibles pour se protéger des
forts autrement dit si on ne croit pas
dans l'idée d'égalité la coopération
devient impossible
c'est la porte ouverte à la guerre de
tous contre tous
sans concept sans valeur sans fiction
partager rien n'indique plus la violence
et donc ce que nietzsche appelle les
arrières monde ce sont les systèmes
idéologiques prétendument transcendant
censé réguler les comportements sociaux
et guider nos actions individuelles
donc les arrières monde ça regroupe les
religions avec leur distinction entre
l'au delà et l'ici bas les systèmes
moreau qui font la séparation entre le
bien et le mal mais aussi les
conceptions métaphysique
le mot même de métaphysique présupposant
une distinction entre le physique et ski
et d'au-delà du physique
mais dans tous les cas ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que la croyance dans
des fictions est une condition de la
civilisation
toute civilisation a besoin de fiction
pour perdurer
toute civilisation a besoin de mythes
qui justifie qui guident et qui
transcende nos comportements
andy nous devons croire dans nos
fictions pour pouvoir coexister
les églises s'enracine dans des mythes
religieux commun les zetas en assignant
des mythes nationaux commun les systèmes
judiciaires s'enracine dans des mythes
ses lego commun pourtant aucune de ces
choses n'existe or des histoires que les
gens inventent et se racontent les uns
aux autres nous comprenons aisément que
les primitifs s'ils manquent leur ordre
social en croyant aux fantômes et aux
esprits et se rassemble à chaque pleine
lune pour danser autour du feu de camp
ce que nous saisissons mal c'est que nos
institutions modernes fonctionnent
exactement sur la même base
alors ici il est très important de
préciser quelque chose c'est que
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
une fiction n'est pas un mensonge
un mensonge c'est quelque chose que l'on
sait être faut que l'on sait ne pas
correspondre à la réalité mais ceux qui
croient dans une fiction collective ne
mentent pas ils ne mentent pas aux
autres il ne se vante même pas à eux
mêmes puisqu'ils croient dans cette
fiction
si vous croyez en dieu vous croyez
sincèrement dans son existence
et à chaque fois que vous utiliser de
l'argent pour payer quelque chose vous
croyez dans la réalité de cet argent
une fiction n'est pas un mensonge
puisque par définition croire dans une
fiction c'est croire dans sa réalité
c'est croire que cette fiction n'est pas
une fiction
de la même façon que quand un enfant
croit au père noël la croyance de
l'enfant est réelle et pour l'enfant le
père noël n'est pas un mensonge
est ce que l'amour est un mensonge
est ce que l'argent est un mensonge
est ce que les droits de l'homme sont un
mensonge
si vous répondez oui à l'une de ces
questions vous devez répondre oui aux
deux autres
contrairement aux mensonges une réalité
imaginaire est une chose à laquelle tout
le monde croit tant que cette croyance
commune persiste la réalité imaginaire
exerce une force dans le monde depuis la
révolution cognitive les sapiens ont
donc vécu dans une double réalité d'un
côté la réalité objective des rivières
des arbres et des lions de l'autre la
réalité imaginaire des dieux des nations
et des sociétés au fil du temps la
réalité imaginaire est devenue toujours
plus puissante au point que de nos jours
la survie même des rivières des arbres
et des lions dépend de la grâce des
entités imaginaire comme le dieu tout
puissant
les états unis où google les fictions
sont des forces matérielles l'amour créé
les mariages créer les naissances et les
crimes passionnels
la religion créer des communions créer
des conversions créer des guerres
saintes
l'argent créé les achats créé
l'endettement créer les entreprises
l'homme crée des libertés créer des lois
et d intervention militaire
ces fictions abstraite créer des
réalités extrêmement concrètes
le propre des fictions c'est qu'il
s'agit d'entités non réelle au sens où
elles ne sont pas des réalités
objectives mais elles produisent des
effets réels
en structurant nos opinions et nos
pensées elle détermine la trajectoire de
nos actions
le meilleur exemple étant évidemment les
guerres idéologiques les guerres de
religions sont la résultante physique et
matérielle de la croyance en un ordre
métaphysique et spirituelle
et c'est ce qui fait dire à harari que
l'ordre imaginaire est incorporé dans
l'ordre matériel
la réalité imaginaire n'apparaît jamais
de manière séparée par rapport à la
réalité matérielle
et harari prends un exemple assez
amusant qui est celui des maisons
modernes en nous disant que les maisons
modernes comporte des pièces cloisonné
chaque pièce à sa fonction et chaque
habitant de la maison possède sa propre
chambre
donc l'adolescent vie dans sa chambre
dans laquelle on entre par une porte
porte qui comporte une serrure et on
n'entre pas dans la chambre de
l'adolescence en avoir frappé et sans
avoir reçu la permission d'entrer
et donc ce que nous dit harari c'est que
la maison moderne la maison cloisonné
c'est la traduction d'un autre monde
matériel de la croyance des occidentaux
dans l'idéologie individualiste
parce que nous sommes gouvernés par
cette fiction de l'individualisme nos
actions concrètes et nos constructions
matériel porte l'empreinte de cette
fiction collective
en d'autres termes nos fictions ont des
effets dans la réalité
de la même façon l'euro et le dollar
sont des fictions mais si votre patron
ne vous donne pas votre chèque à la fin
du mois vous ne pouvez plus manger
c'est donc d'une création imaginaire que
dépend votre survie matérielle
les fictions prennent part à la réalité
objective
alors c'est peut-être un point qu'on
peut reprocher à harari le fait de ne
pas s'être réellement attardé sur les
origines de cette tendance de sapiens à
créer des fictions
ce que nous dit harari c'est que environ
soixante dix mille ans avant notre ère
s'est opérée ce qu'il appelle une
révolution cognitive et cette révolution
cognitive s'est caractérisé par trois
faits majeurs
le premier c'est la bipédie le
redressement de sapiens sur ses deux
jambes la bipédie ayant apporté à
sapiens un avantage adaptatif certain
puisque ça allait lui permettre de voir
de plus haut et donc de voir beaucoup
plus loin et ainsi de pouvoir anticiper
l'arrivée des prédateurs
cette vie p17 accompagnée d'une
augmentation du volume du cerveau de
sapiens ce qui nous fait aboutir au
deuxième fait majeur de cette révolution
cognitive l'apparition du langage
il existe du langage chez les animaux
mais il s'agit d'un langage concret
là où le langage abstrait humain permet
la communication et donc la coopération
avec des inconnus
avec l'apparition du langage complexe et
abstrait sapiens allait devenir capable
de nouer des coopérations au delà du
cercle tribal de ces interactions
quotidiennes
et le troisième fait qui est lié à cette
révolution cognitive c'est la
domestication du feu
et c'est là où d'une certaine manière
les problèmes ont commencé parce que
dotés de cette arme redoutable qu'est le
feu sapiens allait en faire un usage
immodéré
parce qu'il était conscient de sa
faiblesse relative par rapport aux
autres espèces animales sapiens n'a pas
hésité à recourir au feu à chaque fois
que c'était possible
et donc c'est ce qui fait que
généralement lorsqu'il arrivait sur un
nouveau territoire
il faisait le ménage en incendiant les
forêts pour se dispenser d'avoir à
chasser le gibier à la lance
donc c'était une manière pour lui
d'économiser du temps et des efforts et
ça selon à harissa représente la
première forme de prédation de sapiens
sur la planète parce que le fait est
qu'à chaque fois que sapiens a mis les
pieds quelque part la diversité de
l'écosystème a considérablement chuté
et donc on peut imputer à cet usage
quelque peu immodéré du feu cette
destruction systématique de la
biodiversité grâce à laquelle ou à cause
de laquelle sapiens est progressivement
devenu le maître du monde
donc c'est dans cette révolution
cognitive soixante dix mille ans avant
notre ère car harry situe l'acte de
naissance véritable de sapiens c'est à
dire de l'être humain tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui un être humain comme
vous et moi dont la caractéristique
distinctive est précisément sa capacité
à créer des fictions
c'est la fiction qui nous a permis
d'imaginer des choses mais aussi de le
faire collectivement ces mythes donne
tout sapiens une capacité sans précédent
de coopérer en masse et en souplesse
pour miser abeilles peuvent aussi
travailler ensemble en grand nombre mais
le font de manière très rigide et
uniquement avec de proches parents louer
chimpanzé coopère avec bien plus de
souplesse que les fourmis mais ils ne
peuvent le faire qu'avec de petits
nombres d'autres individus qu'ils
connaissent intimement sapiens peut
coopérer de manière extrêmement flexible
avec d'innombrables inconnus
c'est ce qui lui permet de diriger le
monde pendant que les fourmis mange
nord-est et que les chimpanzés se sont
enfermés dans les eaux et les
laboratoires de recherche pourra arrive
l'histoire de l'humanité et
l'entrelacement de deux histoires
c'est d'abord l'histoire de la
réunification du monde en créant des
fictions collective partagée par un
nombre d'individus toujours plus grand
l'humanité en arriver à un stade
d'unification sans précédent
unification culturel unification
économique unification politique
mais l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
aussi l'histoire de la bataille de
l'esprit humain contre la nature
de la technosphère contre la biosphère
il y a donc pour peu qu on lit entre les
lignes une double ironie de l'histoire
la première c'est que la destruction et
était une condition de l'unification du
monde
et la deuxième que ce soit par la
fiction autrement dit par l'esprit que
l'emprise de sapiens sur le monde s'est
opéré
car dans les deux cas ce à quoi on
assiste c'est une dématérialisation
c'est par sa dimension immatérielle que
sapiens a étendu son règne sur le monde
matériel
l'histoire de l'humanité c'est
l'histoire de la victoire de l'esprit
sur la matière
histoire commence à quand les humains
inventaire les dieux et se terminera
quand les humains deviendront des dieux
cette citation de harari ne peut prendre
sens qu'une fois récapituler l'histoire
de l'humanité qu'une fois comprise et
admise
l'idée que le cycle humain et le cycle
de la rencontre de l'esprit et de la
matière
l'heure étant
quel est cet esprit et où nous conduire
à t-il je vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]